That rumor about Kevin Costner and "Yellowstone"
is an "absolute lie" … according to the star's
lawyer. But what do Costner's
co-stars have to say about it?
After struggling in Los Angeles in a
series of odd jobs, Kevin Costner won
roles in several B-movies before making
it big in the late '80s with roles in the
hit films "The Untouchables," "Bull Durham"
and "Field of Dreams." The actor sat in the
director's chair for 1990's "Dances
with Wolves" and went on to win two
Academy Awards for Best Director and Best
Picture as one of the Western's producers.
After a few major flops, he kept a relatively
low profile for a Hollywood A-lister,
but in 2018, Costner turned his
skills to the small screen with
his role as family patriarch John Dutton in
Taylor Sheridan's hit drama "Yellowstone."
His performance is one of the boldest
and most enigmatic of his long career,
with his co-stars at one time offering
praise for the veteran performer's on-set
behavior. But these compliments grew few and
far between as the fifth season of the drama
unfolded and Costner's behind-the-scenes actions
allegedly upset some of his fellow performers.
According to a report by Puck, some of the
cast and crew has been, quote, "frustrated by
[Costner's] ego and his unavailability for a few
years now," and rumor has it that "Yellowstone"
could be on its last legs, thanks in part to a
standoff over Costner's very limited availability.
According to the publication, Costner negotiated
that Season 5 would be filmed in two parts,
each with an abbreviated filming schedule. Then,
Costner came down with COVID-19 during principal
photography. It is alleged that the actor refused
to prolong his shooting schedule to make
up for the delay due to his illness.
"If it's progress you seek, do not vote
for me. I am the opposite of progress."
Instead, Costner noted to the cast and crew
that his window for filming had come to an end,
and thus forced his fellow actors to reconvene
months later to shoot his scenes again
— thereby eating into their schedules.
This is also the claim made by Taylor Sheridan,
but Costner disputes the allegations entirely
and claims he was only following the terms
of his contract. According to Marty
Singer, one of Costner's attorneys,
"The idea that Kevin was only willing to work one
week on the second half of Season 5 of
'Yellowstone' is an absolute lie. It's
ridiculous — and anyone suggesting it
shouldn't be believed for one second."
The behind-the-scenes "Yellowstone" filming
schedule controversy is just one element of
a greater portrait regarding Costner's strained
relationship with Taylor Sheridan's production.
A report from Deadline indicated that Sheridan
was frustrated by Costner's limited availability
for "Yellowstone" due to his commitment
to his own upcoming Western frontier saga,
"Horizon," which will be split into four
separate movies, according to Variety.
The Deadline report further alleged
that Paramount was moving to conclude
"Yellowstone" at the end of its
fifth season before developing
yet another spin-off — this time with Matthew
McConaughey as the lead rather than Costner.
Deadline's report paints a grim picture
regarding the future of Costner's corner
of the "Yellowstone" franchise, though several
other reputable sources have muddied the waters.
Such a strategy conflicts with what star
Cole Hauser previously told Entertainment
Tonight about the longevity of the
series and suggests that the issues
surrounding Costner may have precipitated
Sheridan ending "Yellowstone" early.
However, the Hollywood Reporter
spoke to sources who indicated
that Costner departing would not mark an
immediate ending to the series. Meanwhile,
Paramount Network has suggested that both
"Yellowstone" and Costner's role on the drama
are both set to continue. A Paramount
Network spokesperson told Deadline,
"We have no news to report.
Kevin Costner is a big part
of 'Yellowstone' and we hope that's
the case for a long time to come."